now we're going to do the lab on on deep
learning for chapter 10
and we're going to show you how we fit
the the models that we saw in the
chapter
so
we
implement deep learning through the
keras package in r
which is
a front end to tensorflow which is the
system developed at google
and
keras and tensorflow are implemented in
python
and so there are package keras
interfaces to the python code
so this is this is
quite a different level to what we've
seen up till now
so
in order to be able to run
keras
as we do in this in this lab you need to
have a python implementation on your
machine
on your computer
so it's a little bit of a learning curve
but it's manageable
on the book website
there's a instructions on how to install
keras tensorflow and python on your
machine
for all the the popular machines
and this the the carer system that we
use follows the book by francis
charlotte and j.j eller
called deep learning with r
and uh and so it may be
useful to to get a copy of this book as
well
so we assume that you have keras up and
running on your machine if you want to
follow through on the slab
now the other thing we're doing in this
lab is you'll see there's a lot of text
and
for the new edition of the book we've
we've
presented all the labs and give code for
all the labs in a number of formats one
of them is our markdown format which is
what you see here
and this
pretty much faithfully
reproduces exactly what's in the lab in
the book
so it's a good opportunity to learn the
ins and outs of our markdown
which is really a good way of of
of writing our code and recording what
you're doing and and the trains of
thought and so on and you're running our
mark down in what environment here ah
so we're running this in our studio
itself so this is our studio window
and it unders of course understands our
markdown and you'll see there's a really
nice interface for for running our
markdown okay so let's get started so
you see a lot of text
and in fact if you were to
to knit this file
it would chug along and it would produce
an html document in this case
that when you look at it it's going to
look just like the lab
modulo a few tiny little
maybe differences but it'll look pretty
much like the lab
so here we scroll down
and
the first thing we do is we're going to
implement the single layer network on
the hitters data
which we saw
in the the chapter
we take library islr2 so
for the second edition of the book
we've got a new library which is pretty
much includes the old library press
whatever additional
data sets and maybe functions we need in
the second edition and it's called islr2
which you can get from cran
and then the first few lines are reading
in the hitters data
the hitter's data's got
missing values
so we we use the function naomit to
remove all rows with missing values in
fact
and then we also set the random seed
and we we select a test set
which is going to be one third of the
the data set okay and so to implement
this whole chunk i'm just going to press
the arrow key here
and
and there it's done
okay no output it just does it
and then we're going to fit a linear
model which of course this is familiar
so we use the lm function
the response is salary
so this this is the baseball hitters and
celery of the the batsman
twiddle dot again means to use all the
other variables except salary as they're
as as features
and we use getters minus test id so
we're going to use the training data so
we subset out the test data
and then we do a prediction on the test
data
and then we compute the test error so
i'll just do it first of all
and we see in this interface
the the output just appears on on the
screen in the markdown so that's very
convenient
so that's the mean absolute prediction
error on the test data
now we used another incantation that
we've not necessarily used before and
that's the function with which is really
nice
so with takes as a first argument a data
frame
and then the subsequent
expression can use any of the variables
by name in the data frame and compute
something
and so that's what we did here so
with getter's test id so using that as
the data
we're able to just reference l pratt and
salary and compute the the mean absolute
error
so that's nice
okay the next thing we're going to use
is glimnic because we want to fit a
lasso model
to the the hitters data will get us
right
glimnet doesn't
know about formulas they're not
implemented in glimnit so we need to
make an x and a y matrix
and so
we use a function model matrix which is
a handy function it can take a formula
in this case
we tell it salary is the response
because we want it to exclude it
dot means again all the variables and -1
means we don't want an intercept
otherwise model matrix would normally
include an intercept and you tell it the
data
and then we and we call that x
and y is the salary data
and we've actually wrapped the function
scale around that model matrix and scale
will
standardize the columns to have unit
variance and mean zero i thought we
normally have intercepts why are we
excluding one now
ah good point rob we do want an
intercept in the model
but glimnet when you give it an x it
expects just the the variables and it
automatically puts in an intercept so if
we left the intercept in there'd be two
constants in the model and you i guess
you'd also shrink the intercept which
you don't normally want to do
exactly right right
so i've clicked that chunk and that that
will have implem that will have run that
code
okay so the next thing is we we library
libraryglimnit
we use a cv.glimnet
on the training data in other words
x minus test id comma y minus test id
and we tell cv dot glim that the the we
want to use mean absolute error
otherwise it would use by default mean
squared error
and then we make predictions um from
that model
and we tell it to make the predictions
at lambda.min which is the minimum value
on the cross-validation curve
and we compute the mean absolute error
and so we run that code
some message to say that it's uh loaded
the glimnet package and it implements it
we didn't plot the cross validation
curve yet but we we could have i can
just jump into my code here and just say
plot
cv
fit
and just run that single line
and we get the
the plot of the the cv
fit
but we didn't include that in the in the
package
okay so now we're ready to fit a neural
network so
we load the keras library
and now we write some code to build up
the structure of the model
right
so
the model is called mod nnn so it's a
structure that stores
the the details of what the model is
going to look like
so keras model the sequential is just
some
code that says it's going to be a
feedforward neural network
and then
we'll tell you more about the pipe in a
moment
we pipe it into
a call to layer dense which tells you
that there's going to be 50 units at the
hidden layer with radio activation
and the input shape is going to be the
number of columns of x so in other words
it's going from the input layer with
number of columns of x to the hidden
layer which is 50 units
and then we want to
we pipe that into the layer dropout
where we have a dropout rate of 0.4
and then into the layer dense which is
for the output unit
okay
so this
well let's run that
and you'll see it waits a while while
it's running it because what's going on
in the background is
the python
gets
fired up and there's a whole lot of
stuff sprinted it might look scary when
you see it but
there's nothing really bad in that and
it's just saying that the python's been
implemented
and this model specification has been
transmitted to the python program that's
running
okay
so
let's talk about the pipe operator this
is not something we've encountered
before and it's really useful and
especially for specifying neural network
models because it makes the code
much more readable because we can
basically
put in separate lines for each layer in
the network including things like
dropout okay
so how does it work well we'll
illustrate it on a simple example
so earlier we used
the scale command we made model matrix
and then wrapped around its scale
which would take the output of model
matrix and apply the scale function
and without argument scale by default
standardizes to mean zero and constant
variance each of the columns okay
but these compound expressions can be a
little bit difficult to read right
especially if they get nested
a few layers deep
so here we do the same thing
but using the pipe operator
so we call model matrix
and we want to assign it to x but
what we do is we pipe the output of
model matrix into the scale function
with no arguments
and what that does
is the output of model matrix becomes
the first arg the pipe causes that to be
the first argument to scale
and then any other arguments that are
listed in scalia will be the subsequent
arguments
okay
so that has the same effect as as doing
the scale
there's no need to run it because we've
already done the scale
okay
well good back to the neural network so
we've set up mod n n and it's got some
details um of the the foot it's got a
dropout layer
and so on
now we're gonna add further details to
mod n
that control the fitting algorithm
okay
so we're going to just follow the
the examples given in the keras book
we're going to use squared error loss
and so well again we
pipe mod nnn into compile loss equals
mean squared error we tell it the
optimizer it's a default optimizer and
we tell it the metrics we're interested
in mean absolute error
so
in this previous line the pipe operator
passes modern in as the first argument
to compile
so the
compile function does not actually
change the r object mod n in this case
but it does communicate these
specifications to the corresponding
python instance of this model that has
been created along the way
so this is sort of interesting what's
going on here it looks like we
we created and we're going to fit this
mod n in r but actually what we're doing
is transmitting
this information
to the the python instance on how it's
going to fit the model
so it's a very special kind of thing
that's going on
okay now we're going to fit the model
it's going to use stochastic gradient
descent
and we're going to specify the number of
epochs and the batch size
so
the batch size is going to be 32 which
means that each time
we do a gradient update we randomly
select 32 of the training observations
for computing the the gradient the batch
gradient
and we make a move down the break
gradient and was that specified already
the batch sizing
no rob um
that's that's coming up so this is sort
of preamble to that but so maybe we
should look at it
okay
so this is where we're going to say it
um you can see we've we've actually
commented out
it in the actual lab it says 1500 epochs
that would take a little bit long
so we're gonna we we
cop we commented it out and changed it
to 600. in fact i'm going to get this
thing running right now
because it takes a little while
and then i'll tell you about the the
epochs
so yeah so batch size of 32
there's 176 training data
observations so if you divide that by 32
there's going to be about
five
gradient steps per epoch because
remember an epoch is the equivalent
number of gradients gradient steps so
that you've gone through the whole
training data set once
on the right here we see actually a
progress plots
of the neural network fitting this is
particular to our studio where this
happens
in the top we've got the default loss
which is squared error loss
the green curve is the validation it's
actually the test data in this case and
the blue is the is the training
and down below we've got mean square
mean absolute error same story
blue is training
green is validation
they pretty much on top of each other
the two and notice the the training loss
is is is a little bit jumpy and that's
because this gradient descent is
kind of jumpy because it's there's some
randomness in in in the
observations used for
for computing the gradient it hasn't
hasn't really overfit at all is that
right it doesn't look like it's overfit
at all yeah so we could have actually
gone on a bit longer
and that's an interesting point rob
because
it seems often that these neural
networks
are slow to overfit
and
it's partly i guess the learning rate
there's a
i forget what the learning rate is here
we didn't actually specify it i don't
believe it's a default but it's a
small learning rate so that's
how far you go down the gradient each
time you use dropout as well which
regularizes right and the dropout as
well yeah
there's also a window yo which shows all
the the
more details of each of the gradient
steps
um
and you can wade through that if you
wish but with the plot it's kind of good
enough so we'll just
move that away
um there's a little
little
item here that you can use to open up
those those guys
you can also
directly plot the history if you're not
in our studio and you're running are in
a different system you can directly
produce a plot and you get something
like that which is is very similar to
the plot we've just seen okay
all right
so
just a point um so we ran the foot yeah
we did it with 600 iterations
so if we ran the foot a second time
it would start from where we left off
um because the python code has just kind
of stopped where it is and and if you
run for it again it'll just continue
the plot would continue but it would
continue starting from the the point
where it had
ended before we won't do that now
so the end at the end of the day we
we can use the predict method for for
keras
and uh for neural networks and we give
it the test data
and we evaluate the performance on the
test data
and this is
slightly different to to what we
reported in the book because we only
used a training sample of size 600.
and it's about the same as the least
squares i think a little worse it's yeah
yeah exactly
and the other thing to note and we point
this out in the chapter is that
even if you had to run the model right
from the beginning 1500 steps
a second time it wouldn't give exactly
the same answer because of the slight
randomness in the in the stochastic
gradient descent even with the same seed
well the seed is
is a sticky issue with keras rob because
it turns out it's it's difficult
or we haven't figured out how to set the
python seed from inside keras yeah
so that that's a slight
that's a
slight issue
okay
so that's the end of the simple example
we now move to a multi-layer network on
the mnist digit data this is a bigger
more serious data set
and
these data are available from the keras
package as are other
important data sets for our for our lab
there's actually a dedicated command in
keras called dataset underscore mnist
to get the data
and then we have a few commands to pull
off
this is an object with a lot of com a
list with a lot of components and we
pull off the x the y
x test y test these are all designated
training and test sets
and and make them available
and you'll see that there's 60 000
training images each 28 by 28 grayscale
images
and 1000 test images and of course the
class labels
are
between zero and nine these are the
digits
so
the images the the
the data the x matrix is stored as a
three-dimensional
array
right it's got 60 000 by 28 by 28.
so we actually want to reshape that into
a matrix so we're going to flatten out
the 28 by 28
and there's commands in the keras
package for doing that and we're also
going to turn
the response
into a categorical variable using
keras command 2 categorical
so this is just to turn the input into a
format that the the neural network
understands
one other thing when you fit neural
networks it's not it's pretty sensitive
to the scale of the variables
so you know if you have one variable
that ranges from 0 to 1 and another
variable that
ranges from minus 500 to plus 500
it's going to cause some problems with
the neural network
and so it's generally better to
scale the variables
maybe to an interval say 0 1 or to
standardize them to have say unit
variance
to avoid that sensitivity
so in the case of these images each bit
is
an 8-bit grayscale value and the actual
numbers if you look at them they lie
between 0
and 255 that's 2 to the 8
different numbers right so we'll rescale
them to lie between 0 and 1
and that's a simple command
just does element-wise on x-train and
x-test
okay
so now the data are ready
for the neural network
so again a call to model
a keras model sequential and now we're
going to have more layers so we've got
the
first is the input layer the input
layer's got 784 units it was 28 by 28
images and the first hidden layer is
going to have 256 units with raleigh
activation
pipe that through a dropout layer with
0.4
then the second layer is going to have
128 units also value
we'll do a drop out of 0.3
so that's
a slightly less dropout and then the
final output layer has 10 units that's
and the activation is soft max which
turns the output into probabilities for
the ten classes now how do we decide on
this architecture like the
256 the dropout layer the three the
number of layers the drop-out number of
units that's that's a good question rob
it's actually quite tricky
you'll see this as as we build more and
more complex networks these these
parameters they multiply there's many of
them and why did we use point four here
and point three here
i think i copied it from the keras book
where they used this example
but yeah those are things that that can
sometimes take a lot of time trial and
error to get those right including and
also the number of units although
the general idea is that you make a
large number of units hidden units
and and and you use some form of
regularization so it's better to have
too many than too few yes yeah i think
that's that's the current thinking
so let's make sure we run that code so
again this is not doing much work except
just
specifying the model through these
layers and
making extensive use of the pipe
operator
okay
so we can do a summary of the model and
that's nice because you can actually
check that you did it right
and it gives you a description of each
of the layers and and what's in
and
it looks shocking but we've got
235 000 parameters
right we've only got 60 000 training
observations
so this is a case where the neural
network is way over parametrized
but you know we're going to use
regularization
so who knows what the effective
dimension is but nominally that's how
many parameters there
well we didn't have to blank that out
if you do the parameter if you look at
the parameters
if you wanted to actually reconcile
these numbers with the numbers that we
see here you have to take into account
that there's a bias term which is an
intercept
in each of the layers in the input layer
and each of the hidden layers and when
you add those in you can get to this
number okay
we tell you that the loss is categorical
cross-entropy
that's essentially the the multi-class
logistic regression loss function in
fact
likelihood
and
and we give it details for the
optimization
and and again these
these were prescribed in the keras book
and one can
look up help on these and see what the
different options are but we used
basically the default
so i'll get that running
and now we we fit the model again i've
reduced
down to 15 epochs
i'm using a batch size we're using a
batch size of 128
which may seem really modest given that
we've got 60 000 training observations
but the idea is to use
many
relatively small batches and you may
tend to make better progress
and
and now we tell it to use a validation
split of 0.2 so in fact we're using 20
of the 60 000
training observations as a validation
set so that we can track the history of
the model as it's going
let's see how amazing this is we're
sitting here this is running on a
macbook pro just a just a laptop and
we're fitting how is it 250 000
parameters
250 000 parameters and each each
movement here
is means it's processed 60 000
observations or a bit less because of
the validation split but totally amazing
i guess the credit for that it goes to
goes to google and tensorflow and all
the all the smarts they use both
software and hardware yes yeah it's
amazing
it is amazing we're really blessed to
have
packages like tensorflow available right
and it's used
in you know all over the place
okay
so here's some details of the machine
and uh and
sort of along the lines that that rob
brought up you know that's
fit in the model
it says it took two point
uh it took 144 seconds for the full
model if we used all the epochs
on this particular macbook pro which is
at 2.9 gigahertz or 32 gigabytes of ram
okay
we can
score the model for accuracy
and it does an amazing
98
accuracy on the
test data
which is is really good again we use the
pipe command here
so here we actually wrote a little
function called accuracy
which is takes as an argument to
predictions
and the second argument the truth
and just computes
the mean
classification error so it looks to see
how often
um the predictions are equal to the
truth
we use the word drop because
the predictions are come in the form of
arrays and and we don't want them to get
in the way
and so
we run predict.classes we give it x dot
test that'll give
predictions
for the digit class and we just pipe
that straight into accuracy
and
when you use the pipe command we only
have to name the test set
right which is the second argument
because the first argument is
is
is the output of predom classes
and and that's how it's used
so
in the chapter we also report the
results of lda
which is uh
described in chapter four of the book
and multi-class logistic regression
so
packages like glimnet can handle
multi-class logistic regression just
fine but there turns out they're quite
slow on such a large data set
and we tried
other packages in r to fit the
multi-class logistic regression on these
data
and we ran into problem speed and or
other problems with all
and then it occurred to us that we could
actually fit this model using a deep
network with no hidden layers
which is is kind of nice
so here we go
right
um
so we just we just go from input
straight to output
right using again the softmax activation
right and if you do the parameter count
here you'll find out that's exactly
right for multi-class logistic
regression
and now we fit the model just as before
and this one looks like i'm doing all
30 epochs
and it's fitting that logistic
regression model doing a little bit
worse i think is that why are we up at
90
yes five before yes so we were up at 98
before
and so you can see the advantage
rob of the of the
the neural network
because logistic regression looks like
it gets to about 93
on on the test data
and and the neural network got to 98 so
would this give exactly the same answer
as glimnet is if we could run glumnet it
would yes well exactly nice it wouldn't
right
well it's an approximation right it's
doing stochastic gradient descent so
it's not actually getting to the
the global minimum ah that's a good but
maybe who cares if it performs better
it it performs yeah it'll perform as as
well as glimnit
well approximately as well and it
probably very similar right probably it
seems like it's it's it's leveled off
here